there are new worries tonight for the
president over the Special Counsel
investigation a conservative writer and
associate of Trump confidant Roger stone
says he's talking with Robert Miller's
team about a plea deal exactly what
Jerome Corsi knows and what it mean for
the president are not clear tonight
what is clear it is not good news for
mr. Trump correspondent Kevin cork is
outside the president's Florida Resort
tonight good evening Kevin evening Mike
your right to roam Corsi and I can't
stress this enough is not directly tied
to President Trump though as you
mentioned he is an associate of Roger
stone who was a Trump advisor back in
2016 but what we do know is se continues
to possibly create a situation which
could lead to a plea deal with the
Muller team certainly that is newsworthy
and I think everyone can agree it may
not be very good news for the president
the written answers to the witch hunt
that's been going on forever no
collusion no nothing
they've been finished while the
president remains steadfast in his
denial of any Russian collusion
connected to his campaign the special
counsels office continues to tighten the
net on a number of individuals who were
close to the Trump orbit the latest
jerome corsi
who like former Trump adviser Roger
stone has been linked to the
controversial website Infowars and is
reportedly in talks with the Muller team
about a possible plea deal stemming from
the ongoing Russia probe the Muller team
questioned Corsi as part of an
investigation into stones connections
with the website WikiLeaks and its
founder Julian Assange Muller is trying
to determine where the stone and other
Trump associates had advanced knowledge
of WikiLeaks plans to release damaging
Clinton emails during the campaign if a
plea deal is agreed to
of course he would join more than a
half-dozen others convicted by the
Muller team though none of the accused
has been convicted of crimes related to
Russian collusion involving the Trump
campaign while the coursing news
reverberate across Washington the
president joined the holiday break in
Florida kept his focused at least online
on the ongoing crisis at the border
where thousands of migrants have
collected hoping to push their way into
the u.s. by way of asylum but from the
installation of miles of razor wire to
the hours long shutdown of one port of
entry
to the authorization of the use of
lethal force by the military the Trump
administration has rebuffed that effort
instead applying pressure on Mexico
where there is increasing pressure to
move the migrants in one direction or
the other you can't have borders
you're not borders you don't have a
country if we find that it's it gets to
a level where we are gonna lose control
or our people are going to start getting
hurt we will close entry into the
country for a period of time until we
can get it under control while critics
may reject the administration's policies
the president on Twitter today seemed
content to pass the problem to Congress
calling a Republicans and Democrats to
come together adding that after 40 years
of talk it is finally time for action
Mike it is unclear what course he might
plead guilty to or even offer a plea for
although previously he has suggested he
may be indicted for allegedly lying to
federal prosecutors Mike all right
something to watch there Kevin